でももう一歩なんですよ本当にデブ
きれい
ん
そういうのよさあやってまいりましたよ
今回おきましては今回めっちゃおりましたやい人気客
ブックウィーク増やすような肌を能化のコーナー
ねえかごらー件の大量摂取にどんな句ですけれども結局からいうとまあ失敗
てでもん
主力はなって待ってあるけど今後も引き続きね彼の肌のかだ室を買いですね肌に良い
情報をみなさん伝えればいいなと思っております今回用意した曲は子連れ
バイ
はいはいえー今回はこちらを使ってきます覚醒スッキリ黒パッグやーだーパックですね
という感じで貼ってめくると毛穴の角質がとれるというつでございますあの北2学校の
時
多分沢民の日にならないけどニキビひどかった絶対外相は6中国 google 労組
みたいなコースだからね結構ひどくていろいろニキビにつれ調べたんですけども
なぜに君がを受けるかというと毛穴が詰まってしまって炎症が起きているんですって
いうのはもう単純な話変なを開いて汚れよとってスッキリさせれば
ヶ月前に行けば減るんじゃねーかというかこうばさがパスなんで広範囲に及んでいるの
で何だけではなくよならないか広範囲に及んで白質を綺麗にして
いければいいなと思っておりますもうあるいはがいられるとなわけで今日こそ俺が資料
を阻止崩していきましょう
あと前回のいきたいにゃん全体と同じ毛が期待できるよ
ここは物理的に本当に角質が取れてるわけ交換会
チェーンなパック500枚準備しましたーー
もうあなたの穴という穴各一便でぐっとエッこういう感じになってるんだ
10万入ってますじゃあさっそく買っていきましょうまずはまんべんなく火を揺らす
いきます
うん
また eu するんだけど何これダメ女てるだけです
同じでこれら分でらさないと肌が荒れたんで私綺麗じゃないしていくことが大事で
ございますねいい感じで濡れてますねでここだがスピード創部でなるべく匠の家にパッ
クっていきましょう
こういう感じがいいんじゃないんじゃないに良い月に数
塗っていけばいい感じでどんどん貼っていきます梅田人ができる住んでると思うよえっ
me
plume いってればとっ
続も貼ってるとプロセスがあります
ん
はいという気で顔はほぼ完成したのであとは体ですね
握りというのは体のどこにできるかわかりましたよ毛穴が詰まったら詠唱が起きて指に
なってしまいますのでなるべくある分だけで埋めていこうと思います
んん
ん
そこで混ぜ巧みな肌綺麗だったらこの企画俺じゃんっていうんだよねー
第三男戦闘 jr だって
前口周りは避けろって書いてあったんで区長あり矢先時はスタートでごめんなさい
えっ
[音楽]
ん
はいというわけで羽根はれました
私ですね今これで毛穴パックで違う穴を開けて中のその角質とか古い
あれを通りだしております今の感想は木にくいですはいやってすというわけでそれで
閉経トレ前にぐるっと回ってみてもらいましょうか
くっ
ちょっ
おおーー
ホラー月はばちょっとぐれてしまってよく受け
papasan
[拍手]
しません
海底でこんな感じでですね全体的に貼ってあるんですけどもこれ今から全部とって毛穴
キレイになった本人とこれはれ前だった日 boa の彼を比較してみましょう
あーうーをすごい
ねぇ
滑っつをてるじゃん大蛇の顔なんですよね1枚爪をするか
[音楽]
ちょっとこいてる入っていけない痛い
ではさいどれだけ取れているかですねー
[音楽]
おっ
色を取れているとれてるをすごいすごいすごい
ねっとりとれる頑張って本当にただきれいなだけでも運動
[音楽]
そう呼ぶねうん
me
バッハ